What if when you pressed on, you were on the Internet in seconds?
What if your browser was your operating system?
And so check this out:...
...This means that you don't have to deal with managing programs...
...or nagging updates, or lost files, or confusing settings,...
...or Blue Screens of Doom.
And there are no nagging updates,...
...just your browser.
Which means you can still listen to music,...
...you can watch movies, interact with friends, you're creating documents,...
...you're playing games, you're writing your e-mails. You're doing all of this stuff...
...that you're already doing on the Internet.
But here's the thing, none of this is stored on your computer.
What?! None of it, you ask?
Yeah, none of it.
Really nothing?
Yeah, nothing is stored on your computer.
Well, where is it?
It's on the Internet.
You know, like when you access your e-mails from your computer and your phone,...
...the e-mail, it isn't stored on either device.
So, if everything's stored on the Internet,...
...then your phone, your computer, all of these devices are what people call, stateless.
Which is kind of a big word so maybe just remember this:...
...Chrome is a totally rethought Web browser,...
...you could download it right now on your computer.
But Chrome OS is a totally rethought computer...
...that lets you stop worrying about your computer...
...so you could focus on the Internet.
Which is what most of us use our computers for nowadays, anyways.